a couple others okay so here's an idea
so I was talking to my cousin and as we
were talking about like one of my
cousins he's young he goes on dates uses
the apps boom boom boom and then like
our aunts and uncles are always like oh
my God look at him he's just swiping
left and right he goes on dates it's
like really foreign concept to them and
so that was one data point okay just
kind of notice wow my aunts and uncles
they really don't get it when it comes
to this online dating thing data point -
I'm watching the debate and it was I
watched so much online that when I
watch traditional TV first of all it's
so slow and secondly I start to see the
commercials and I'm like oh this is
what's being advertised to mainstream
America like cars it's very fascinating
so like Noom was on there which is like
the diet like nutrition plan thing they
do really really well you know I am we
should break them down later they
advertise but the other one was some it
was the this gray haired woman comes on
the on the screen and she's like Oh
online dating where do I start and then
it's like well open up your browser type
www.a
and then start clicking around like that
was literally that was the ad was like
how do I even get started as like here's
how you get started online dating I
remember the name oh come on it wasn't
like a match or I'd never heard of it
before
so I started thinking and I was like you
know there's so many people that are
sort of in my sort of extended family
and whatnot that are divorced and
they're alone and so I was thinking
about them I was like you know it'd be
great if they found someone but the
reality is they don't do a lot of online
dating because it's so scary in foreign
and it's not the online part that's
scary it's the expectation that you then
need to go meet somebody and so like
let's take my uncle for example my
uncles I don't know 65 years old he is
divorced he gets lonely his kids are all
grown up everyone left the house and you
know he doesn't want to actually like
it'd be great if he met somebody who was
awesome and they could just like be
companions for there stood life
but he's sort of like dude I don't want
to get out there like last time I went
on a date was 40 years ago like I think
I'm just out of the game it's easier to
be lonely than it is to put yourself out
there so anyways long pier
for the idea the idea is a service
that's for older people let's make it
just fifty enough as a rule and it's
called just talking and the expectation
is you're gonna go on here with other
people who are like you are sort of
single might be alone looking for
companionship but it's just talking you
can't meet it's not their real names
it's nothing it's just somebody you
could log onto the computer and just
talk to either through audio or text and
you could talk to them continuously or
you could switch and pick somebody else
and talk to them but it's just
companionship as a service for and it's
not dating you're not gonna start going
out with this person you're not trying
to get remarried you just get in the
reps in you just don't want to be lonely
at home anymore and honestly you can
have a virtual relationship you know
through this and it's because I was also
watching love is blind so and I was like
dude somebody should make an app that's
just this now off the back of the idea
and so anyways these are sort of some
ideas what do you learn about it by I
love it I love it Witter that's a winner
what I would do is I would go and do
research on the sex hotlines that used
to exist that probably don't exist
anymore right and I would want to learn
how they work I bet they crushed so I'll
shout out something like tangentially
related so sex hotline related but
obvious a surpise or sex that killed it
then there's one startup out here in San
Francisco called Papa have you heard of
this Papa yeah Papa is grandkids as a
service so it's just young people but
you that will just come over to your
grandparents house and just do stuff for
them and like talk to them but like also
do their laundry and like take out that
trash I don't know if they're doing well
or not they just launched it raised a
bunch of money and because there's this
huge aging population of the baby
boomers and so there's a wealth of
opportunities that are for the this the
largest generation of people ever in
America is now getting old and I forgot
this woman was calling it the the the
grey new world and for gray hair so
she's like you know the grey new world
hood opens up all these possibilities so
one is Popeye which is grandkids as a
service one is honor because I know
honor there's a huge shortage of
caretakers for for the elderly and so
honor is a on demand caretaker platform
that you know so your track here are you
going with caring for old people or
helping people get laid I'm talking
about just talking that's my idea
I was just tangentially saying there's
some other businesses that are trying to
help this relation right here
what did they do never heard of that now
Jack invested in it and he says it's
going well it's called a relationship
here relationship here calm and they
teach you how to do online dating okay
just coaching for all night having go
can you go to really pull that out
that's how it started as it might be a
little bit different for you yeah this
would be for younger people that would
be for whoever I think if you did just
talking and you ran a bunch of Facebook
ads you could get a lot of people to pay
to be a part of a community of people
where they can have these online
relationships aisle expectation is you
do not go offline I think it's great no
I think it's great is because the way
the way that you're positioning it is is
as a marketplace those are notoriously
hard to make but once you have them
they're great yeah the reason why I like
this is you can kind of fake it at first
yeah so you can just hire people you can
have some operators yeah better than
providing that companion I think it's a
great idea you could seed the
marketplace with the operators yeah I
think it's awesome we talked about only
fans yeah that's training today on
Twitter is it yeah worldwide because of
what some strikes it got down I didn't
get the joke I clicked on it and try to
understand it and I didn't right I
didn't get it one out of three Twitter
trends yeah it was a top only fans which
we talked about only fans great business
but I loved just talking I think I think
that's a great idea
thank you thank you for thank you very
much
[Music]